you can make an argument by the way that
nobody should have these things and I
would defend that argument I would I
would like saying look llms and Ai and
machine intelligence can cause a lot of
harm so nobody should have it and I will
respect someone philosophically with
that position just like I will respect
someone philosophically with the
position that nobody should have guns
right but I will not respect
philosophically which it with with
Only The Trusted authorities should have
access to this yeah who are The Trusted
authorities you know what I'm not
worried about alignment between
AI company and their machines I'm
worried about alignment between me and
AI company
what do you think of the azra yadkowski
would say too
because he's really against open source
I know and
thought about this I thought about this
and
I think this comes down to a repeated
misunderstanding of political power by
the rationalists
interesting
I think that Elias yutkowski is scared
of these things and I am scared of these
things too everyone should be scared of
these things these things are scary
but now you ask about the two possible
Futures one where a small trusted
centralized group of people has them and
the other where everyone has them
and I am much less scared of the second
future than the first
well there's a small trusted group of
people that have control of our nuclear
weapons
there's a difference again a nuclear
weapon cannot be deployed tactically and
a nuclear weapon is not a defense
against a nuclear weapon
except maybe in some philosophical mind
game kind of way
but AI is different different how
exactly okay let's say the intelligence
agency deploys a million bots on Twitter
or a thousand bots on Twitter to try to
convince me of a point
imagine I had a powerful AI running on
my computer saying okay uh nice psyop
nice psyop nice psyop okay here's a
psyop I filtered it out for you
yeah I mean so you have fundamental hope
for that
for the for the defense of psyop I'm not
even like I don't even mean these things
in like truly horrible ways I mean these
things in straight up like ad blocker
right yeah sure bad blocker I don't want
ads yeah but they're always finding you
know imagine I had an AI that could just
block all the ads for me
so you believe in the
the power of the people to always create
a knob blocker
yeah I mean I I kind of share that
belief I have that's the one of the
deepest optimisms I have is just like
there's a lot of good guys
so to give you don't you shouldn't hand
pick them just throw out powerful
technology out there and the good guys
will outnumber and outpower the bad guys
yeah I'm not gonna say there's a lot of
good guys I'm saying that good outnumber
is bad right good outnumbers bad in
skill and performance yeah definitely in
skill and performance probably just a
number two probably just in general I
mean if you know if you believe
philosophically in democracy you
obviously believe that
um that good out number is bad and like
the only if you give it to a small
number of people
there's a chance you gave it to good
people but there's also a chance you
gave it to bad people if you give it to
everybody
well if good outnumber's bad then you
definitely gave it to more good people
than bad
that's really interesting so that's on
the safety grounds but then also of
course there's other motivations like
you don't want to give away your secret
sauce well that's I mean I I look at
respect capitalism I don't think that I
think that it would be polite for you to
make model architectures open source and
fundamental breakthroughs open source I
don't think you have to make way to open
source you know what's interesting is
that
like there's so many possible
trajectories in human history where uh
you could have the next Google be open
source so for example
I don't know if that connection is
accurate but you know Wikipedia made a
lot of interesting decisions not to put
ads like Wikipedia is basically open
source you could think of it that way
yeah and like that's one of the main
websites on the internet yeah and like
it didn't have to be that way it could
have been like Google could have created
Wikipedia put ads on it you could
probably run amazing ads now on
Wikipedia you wouldn't have to keep
asking for money but it's interesting
right so llama open source llama
derivatives of Open Source lava might
win the internet
I sure hope so I hope to see another era
you know the kids today don't know how
good the internet used to be
and I don't think this is just all right
come on like everyone's nostalgic for
their past but I actually think the
internet before small groups of
weaponized corporate and government
interests took it over was a beautiful
place